hey everyone thanks for coming to this
afternoon session where we'll be talking
about visual effects and animation
rendering on gcp my name is Todd Priebus
I'm a product manager here at Google and
I focus on solutions for the media and
entertainment vertical so during this
particular session we've got some Oscar
caliber customers we're going to share
with you their experience of using gcp
to render imagery that's high-quality
cost-effective helps them deliver
projects on time and really most
importantly as far as visual effects
animation goes it serves the creative
purpose of the story so I'll start by
giving you a brief overview talk a
little bit more about what rendering is
at a high level we'll look at some of
the things that gcp has done to enable
studios to achieve really great high
scale rendering and then we'll hear from
Annie Bradshaw Monique's VP of business
development and operations at conductor
I oh there a cloud rendering platform
running on gcp and their customer atomic
fiction just to just put through several
million hours of rendering on gcp on the
film the walk and this is a film from
Oscar winner Robert Zemeckis and the
film itself was shortlisted for the
Oscar bake-off for Best Visual Effects
this year after Monique will hear from
Brennan Chapman he's the head of
pipeline at moonbot studios they
themselves in oscar-winning studio in
Shreveport Louisiana and brennan's going
to go ahead and share his experience of
using gcp to set up a hybrid environment
for rendering where he's been able to
use his on-premise resources and then
bursts to gcp for excess capacity and
really demanding jobs so to high level
what is rendering well there are several
different variations but really for the
purpose of media entertainment &
animation it comes down to this taking a
model inside of a 3d application that's
been built by an artist and taking all
the data associated with that model so
that could be textures that can be
geometry that could be assets that could
be animation that could be lighting
imagine to accurately like this you
could need to set up thousands of points
of light so it's taking all of this data
and number crunching this to give you a
final fully realized photorealistic
output such as this
so this is a single frame here and to
run this render on a 32 core machine
takes about an hour just to give you a
little bit of context of what this one
particular rendering job is but keep in
mind the scale of most projects what I'm
showing you here is one frame so to get
one second of animation for a film or
television project you're talking about
24 frames so right there you're looking
at 24 hours on a 32 core machine to
render one second of animation and then
you want to go do 10 seconds of
animation a minute of animation 60
minutes 90 minutes so by the time you're
at a full animated feature film the
numbers are really astounding and in
this particular case it's an hour render
but in the case of the good dinosaur
this is Pixar's last movie actually just
saw these stats two days ago this was a
48-hour a frame I sorry 48-hour render a
frame project so it's something like
175,000 frames each one taking nearly
two days of render time on a hike or
count machine so imagine when you're
delivering a film of this scale and a
disc scope you're looking at renders in
the hundreds of millions of core hours
so it's very daunting it's very
demanding and these numbers are
increasing year-over-year audience
expectations are getting higher and
greater and the demands and the end and
the vision of the director is also
increasing in scope it's also important
to note that rendering isn't just a
really important use case when you're
talking about big animated feature films
or movies with superheroes or spaceships
or dinosaurs it's everywhere so
rendering is really ubiquitous in what
you're seeing on television today at the
cinema or whatever you're watching on
your mobile device and as Monique
Bradshaw is going to talk about in what
in greater detail the walk is a perfect
example of this so this is this is a
character-driven piece it tells the
story of a Frenchman philippe petit who
put a high wire between the two twin
towers of New York and walked across it
so it's there's no spaceships here there
no monsters but in order to create this
environment this photo real world to
help sell the vision of the story the
visual effects studio atomic fiction
that worked on this how to digitally
recreate massive parts of New York and
render this and for a story where
there's nothing obvious as a visual
effect you're still looking at over 9
million core our
needed to make this movie so it's really
important to note that any time you're
watching something on TV at cinema on
your mobile device it's very likely that
there was a significant amount of
rendering required to produce that
output whether or not you realize it and
so what are the challenges associated
with rendering well obviously as we've
demonstrated it's incredibly
computationally intensive and it's also
very bursty both Monique and Brandon
will attribute to the fact that you're
working on a project sometimes for
months at a time maybe your on-premise
capacity is at maximum utilization and
they're always last minute changes that
come in the director has new things they
want to see the scripts winner buys so
you can never have enough capacity
especially in that month or two before
final delivery of a project there's
always a need for more always a need for
more so bursty workloads are really
something you see whether you're working
on a small commercial and you've got
five or six projects coming in at the
last minute or a large feature film
another advantage or another a need to
have centralized compute is in multi
site locations we've really seen the
last five to seven years Studios opening
up worldwide locations so it's not just
one studio working on a project for 10
and 12 hours a day and going home but
instead they'll work on that shot let's
say at the headquarters in London that
shot will get passed off to the team in
Montreal working on it they'll work in
other eight to ten hours and we'll get
passed off to the satellite office in
Singapore so we're seeing more and more
of a 24-hour dynamic workload even among
smaller studios so the need for having
rendering scalable compute resources is
really critical and how does how does
gcp fit into all of this well our
machine capacity obviously is a critical
part to all of this all right gcp is the
network that runs google so what we
serve ads and search and each of all
this was built at Google scale so for us
to have a studio come to us and need to
provision twenty thirty forty fifty
thousand cores in a matter of minutes is
no problem and you can trust that with
the studio having to go out and find the
physical space and bring in all the
machines and set up their networking
oftentimes that they only need it for a
week or two a burst capacity it's really
not feasible
the scalability we offer is really
unparalleled in the industry I think our
pricing model in particular is fantastic
for bursty rendering workloads you only
pay by the minute after a 10-minute
minimum so this allows you to really
scale your workload in parallel going
back to the example I gave before the
police car so let's say that's one hour
to render and I have to render one
second of animation so that's 24 frames
so what I would do on gcp is spin up 24
VMs concurrently and assign one frame to
each of those so there's no longer the
concept of having to wait for a job to
queue behind a limited available number
of machines but the job is done as fast
as possible and that's returned back to
your artists so they can continue to
iterate and revise work in a manner
faster than ever and when it comes down
to running an animation or a visual
effects studio on a day-to-day basis
your highest costs are really that of a
human capital you're paying these
artists several hundred dollars a day to
work on this these shots and if you
think about it if they're sitting there
waiting for these renders to be returned
while they're in a limited on-premise
environment they're not working when
they should be they're not working at
full capacity so not only are you taking
into account the infrastructure spend
but you're also wasting a lot of this
human capital and then specific to the
visual effects in animation and media
entertainment industry we've done a lot
of things at gcp that really
differentiate us many of the competition
out there studio specific security is a
huge issue in our industry often cases
you're talking about a billion dollar
ten pole blockbuster franchises so if
any of that data was to leak ahead of
time the Hollywood production studios
could be looking at hundreds of millions
of dollars of losses so there's an
incredible amount of concern over
putting your data in the cloud when it
comes to this sensitive pre-release
theatrical content so what we've done at
gcp is actually work directly with the
Hollywood production studios educating
them around our security and our
compliance and in several cases we've
actually undergone studio specific
audits of gcp that have awarded us a
tier 1 certification allowing our
customers to put the most sensitive
pre-release theatrical content on our
cloud for rendering workloads we've also
built scalable solutions for all types
of studios
so if you're a small studio and you want
to do rendering on gcp we have a product
called zinc render and this is a turnkey
solution all inclusive no coding needed
and it's literally a plug-in you install
inside of your host application and you
can access tens of thousands of gcp
cores to render your project
instantaneously and for larger studios
with more custom pipelines we have a
dedicated solutions architecture guide
that's been written for us in
conjunction with a technical director
one of the leading studios north america
a studio that's been using gcp for well
over a year and I have to do their
rendering and this is a full breakdown a
step-by-step guide of how to integrate
your existing on-premise infrastructure
and tie that to gcp for rendering
workloads then really the backbone of
all of this is our ISDN relationships so
our industry no matter if you're a
five-person shop or you're a 1500 person
shop the core stock is the same everyone
is working with the same standard
commercial tools they might have their
own additional software that they've
written on top of that but stools like
nuke from the foundry berate from chaos
group and render man from Pixar are the
foundation of all rendering workloads in
media and entertainment so we've worked
very closely with the top is vs in the
industry and if you look at this list
here there's not a single oscar-winning
film over the last 15 years it has not
used some or all of this software here
so we're working very closely with these
ISVs to enable a scalable deployment on
gcp that's concurrent to the scalable
model we offer with our billing and the
results so far I've been awesome we've
seen hundreds of millions of cores now
put through gcp across feature film
commercial advertising episodic
television vr content live action
cinematic rides and animated projects
just to name a few so we're excited to
continue to see this uptake of our
product and I'll go ahead and turn over
now Monique Bradshaw again monique is VP
of business development and operations
at conductor I oh and she's going to
share the story of atomic section honey
thanks Todd as Todd said I'm Monique
Bradshaw from conductor IO conductor IO
is a company that provides cloud
computing as a service we focus on the
image rendering needs of the median
entertainment space and conductor i/o
provided the cloud rendering
capabilities for atomic fiction for the
work that they did on the recent movie
the walk as Todd said movie the walk
tells the story of the true story of
wire Walker philippe petit who strung a
wire illegally between the two towers of
the world trade center and walked across
it without any safety gear at all and
today I'm here to share with you the
story of how cloud computing played a
critical role in atomic of fiction
atomic fictions ability to recreate the
twin towers and the New York City scape
of 1974 for the movie but before I tell
you about the movie the walk I'm going
to tell you a little bit more about how
compute resources are used to create
visual effects for film now Todd touched
on this a little bit but I wanted to go
in a little bit more detail because it
can get pretty complicated so in the
beginning of a shots life and artists
works with a lightweight wireframe
representation of the scene basically
like the top image there now the
relative simplicity of this scene makes
it quick to interact with locally so a
team of artists can work with an
interactive graphics programs to create
recipes for how cameras move how
surfaces are textured and how lighting
it falls on objects now once that recipe
is defined it needs to be baked this
process of calculating how light is
received by reflects off of millions of
surfaces is called rendering and the
results of this process can be seen in
the bottom image now in a film a single
second of footage is typically made up
of 24 images or frames it's not unusual
for a single iteration of a single frame
to take between 5 and 10 hours sometimes
even more to to render on a single
multi-core machine so given that it's
easy to multiply that out and see how a
single iteration of a single second of
film can actually require thousands of
hours of compute time so to understand
how important cloud resources were to
the creation of the effects in the walk
let me talk a little bit about the
hurdles that had to be overcome for this
as i mentioned conductor i worked with
atomic fiction and they were the visual
effects company that was charged with
putting the audience's fourteen hundred
feet above the new york for the climax
of the film the first challenge they had
to overcome was creating the environment
the towers themselves had to be built
perfectly down to every last nut and
bolt an artist then spent months
introducing imperfections to make them
look hand-built the activity in the
streets below from the cars to the
people to the flocks of birds the moving
atmosphere of all created from scratch
the scenery below was created to with
spinning fans and rooftop HVAC systems
rain gutters on buildings hot dog stands
in the streets and changing stoplights
to make the city feel alive every
conceivable camera angle had to be
accommodated and that meant a number of
lighting scenarios everything from
nighttime to early morning to blustery
overcast day to a sunny fall afternoon
all of that flexibility and complexity
meant that a massive amount of compute
time would be required for the walk a
single iteration of one frame required
83 gigabytes of input data and took over
seven hours to render on a 16-core
instance if you multiply that out and
given the nature of production deadlines
it meant that the artist at atomic
fiction we need the ability to access
over 15,000 cores of compute power
simultaneously for sustained periods of
time the second challenge that atomic
fiction had to face was the type budget
that they had to create these effects
now for a medium-sized company to
acquire that amount of compute
infrastructure locally would require a
leasing or renting a large amount of
computer systems as well as sourcing
colocation facility the appropriate
technical support and all of that would
add up to a financial obstacle that
would have blown the budget for them
additionally visual effects companies
don't realize any profit till the end of
a project so it was incredibly important
for atomic fiction that they could get
up and running but this little overhead
is possible this is an important graph
it illustrates the financial challenges
typical of rendering needs in the visual
effects industry so as an example of a
medium sized visual effects studio the
jagged blue line represents atomic
fictions actual work profile and
relevant spend for compute resources the
red line represents typical resource
profile for a growing visual effects
company that's investing in on-premises
resources in this traditional
environment resources are required to
try to cater to the peak need the time
effort and money required to implement
those additional hardware means that the
resource profiles plateau around the
last peak need and they can't adjust
downward to match the actual render
workload at given times so what you can
see here is that the pink shaded area is
where on sorceries on-site resources are
over provision for the actual workload
and that represents wasted investment
the blue shaded area is where on-site
resources were under provisioned for
work load requirements and that
represents a negative impact artist
productivity so as you can see the
spiking nature of typical content
creation workload results in competing
site in companies cycling between the
cost of limited computing power
negatively impacting the productivity of
their artists and too much dead weight
being carried during down times so the
solution to the channel these challenges
of complexity cost and challenging work
profiles was to do as the flexible
capacity of the cloud and that's where
conductor i/o comes in
so atomic fiction utilized conductors
cloud rendering platform to manage its
cloud computing needs for the film now
the benefits of cloud computing can
really be summed up in one word scale if
you take a look at this simple table you
can get a very clear contrast in two
styles of managing work in the first
column you see a thousand tasks spread
across 50 instances that result in a
total turnaround time of 10 hours in the
second column we see the same number of
tasks spread across a thousand instances
resulting in a turnaround time of only
half an hour now as you can see there
are good reasons for each example of
resource allowance but one of the
biggest benefits of elastic scaling is
the ability to scale up rapidly as the
need demands allowing artists iterate
faster that improves productivity and
creative quality by limiting the amount
of time that artists have to wait around
to see the outcome of their work and it
allows them to create be creative and
iterate faster in the same amount of
calendar time large peak capacity and
rapid downscaling lets teams postpone
their render needs until later on the
schedule and that's creatively and
financially beneficial the on-demand
scalability afforded by gcp allows
companies to maintain a direct
relationship between project costs and
revenue no longer do does the studio's
revenue need to cover unused but costly
infrastructure in addition these days
data and analytics are critical aspect
of pretty much any company the scale of
data collection and analysis of large
amounts of metadata that's enabled by
leveraging cloud architecture also
allows for better cost management and
streamlining of workflows so conductors
written on top of the Google cloud
platform and it provides functionality
critical to meeting the needs of a
demanding visual effects production for
us there were a number of key
that were that we needed to evaluate in
choosing to use Google the big one from
a business perspective is the ability to
do permanent building which google
enables when we're providing a service
to an industry where workloads are often
broken down into tasks that require
fractions of hours of compute time this
like the ability to offer true paper use
is a critical aspect and a critical part
of our value proposition now obviously
Google is a global company and that
goggle global presence is incredibly
important for us single customers that
we have may have studios and locations
as diverse as Europe North America and
India and being able to provide a
standardized service that they can
interact with from any location in the
same way is very important also having
access to the vast engineering talent of
Google to help us work through
architecture optimization or resolve
issues gives us the confidence to
provide a service to businesses where
uptime is incredibly important now one
of the Holy Grails for the visual
effects industry is really being able to
mine data for bidding accuracy and
thorough render cost analysis and
accurately predicting the time and cost
for a given render job is also critical
now to do that at scale where we have
thousands or millions of concurrent
tasks generating data consists
constantly we needed a powerful database
option and for us that's big table with
a big table it's huge it's extensible
and it's incredibly responsive and when
we have huge numbers of jobs running at
the same time through conductor we can
then use bigquery to access that data
and present it quickly to our customers
providing them real-time information
about how their work is going finally
google app engine offers us a ton of
configurability out-of-the-box which is
really important for a small company to
get up and not running
quickly and it's an important capability
for our team because it allows us to
focus on implementing our key road map
features rather than worrying about our
application architecture all right so to
talk a little bit about conductor
architecture one of the most important
things for us was to have as little
impact on the artist workflow as
possible so we created plugins that fit
into the most commonly used software for
artists and then that is installed in
the artist local machine other than that
the artist workflow is pretty much
unchanged they work as they always have
they save their data for the right place
in the local network and that's it when
the artist is ready to render they pull
up the conduct the installed conductor
plugin enter a few think it's of
parameters things like choosing the
instance type setting up the frame range
and then they just hit submit the
plug-in then sends those job parameters
to the conductor application what serves
as the brain of the conductor service
the application is hosted in Google App
Engine and there are no initiates a
number of key functions so the app
uploads dependent files and data
including file scripts and environment
variables Veon uploader demon from the
local file system to the cloud where we
also do a deduplication process to make
sure that we're using the storage as
effectively as possible the data is
initially stored in GCS and then
specific instances are spun up to sync
data from GCS to a cluster NFS share and
we we scale up at 100 render instances /
gluster instance in order to meet our
i/o needs now the conductor app also
determines the required number of render
instances and spins up the right number
from google compute engine scaling up
quickly reliably and mass
lovely we run a docker container that's
customized for our execution environment
using docker allows us to potentially
accept custom is excuse me custom images
from customers and that's a major
benefit for highly customized Studios
the render instances read the necessary
input files from the gloucestershire
once all the components are running an
active the google app or scuze me the
conductor app manages the rendering
process from start to finish including
licensing queuing error handling and
metrics collection the web UI also
hosted from google app engine allows
users to control and monitor the render
jobs from wherever they are data stores
used to store the output to store state
and operations job metrics are stored in
bigquery for easy access and also made
available via the web dashboards once a
job completes the output is stored in
GCS and guster NFS for future ease of
use the data is also downloaded to a
local path specified at job submission
so the artists have that in their local
environment again if there are no
further jobs requiring that same
instance configuration then the
conductor app shuts down any unneeded
instances so what does that really mean
and result in when it's put into use
let's take a quick look at a quick
two-minute clip of some of the effects
that were for the walk that were
generated using conductor
so that that gives you an idea of the
real complexity that goes into making a
movie and also it tells you that the
best effects are the ones that you don't
even know are there so here's the final
breakdown for the cloud computing that
went into creating those effects over 9
million core hours were used to create
about 30 minutes of film the the final
portion of the film was was all done
through conductor and of those 39
million hours almost three million of
them were in the last month alone it
gives you amazing evidence of the power
and flexibility of scalability now all
that equated to a peak total of over
15,000 concurrent cores running in
Google cloud for sustained periods of
time another major benefit of the
distributed nature of cloud computing is
how accessible it is to people over the
world for the portions of this movie
worked on by atomic fiction 75 artists
collaborated from two different
locations the Bay Area and Montreal
Canada without any change to workflow or
additional management overhead as you
can see in order to comment the peak
render load we estimate that it would
have cost atomic fiction about 1.5
million dollars to procure the necessary
local infrastructure by using conductor
and the power of cloud computing atomic
fiction realize a cost of about fifty
percent just on render infrastructure
alone now as impressive as all of those
numbers are for me this quote really
captures the the power and the promise
of cloud architecture this is what we
have the ability to do when we are able
to leverage the capabilities and
flexibility of the cloud we have the
ability to fundamentally change the way
in industry works thank you very much
thanks for that money some really great
insight onto how they built their
platform using gcp and some of the
amazing photo real visual effects work
that they completed so now we hear from
Brendan chavin Brennan again the head of
pipeline and oscar-winning moonbot
studios thanks Todd hi Brenda Chapman
head of pipeline at moonbot studios
moonbot is based out of Shreveport
Louisiana about 50 people on staff we've
been honored with quite a few different
awards a couple of projects you might
recognize us from include the fantastic
flying books of mr. morris lessmore by
the Scarecrow as well as the number
leaves these take multiple forms
including short films apps games and
even printed books we pride ourselves as
being a multi-platform storytelling
studio and we use whatever medium that
we see best fit to tell our stories a
story I'd like to share with you day is
called taking flight and it's based on
the life and heritage of Antonio passing
the inventor of the radio flyer wagon
this short was helped was rendered in
part by Google Cloud
you know that wagon used to be your
dance I guess your dad didn't tell you
about aliens you guys enjoyed that so
that sure was great and we use a lot of
crap cloud rendering on it but the
question is why use cloud r internet
Mumbai what is what is the benefit we
get and we prefer to touch them a little
bit but just to state it from an exact
moon by perspective and increases our
creative freedom which is our golden
ticket remove on allows our artists be
more creative and limits them from the
restraints of the fixed capacity of a
local render farm to be able to scale
and accommodate any creative goal and
thus because of that we're able to meet
our deadlines and not go past them which
is huge and also it helps us to save
money as they've stated is we the
rendering is a lot of burst workflow and
if we don't have to buy a local compute
farm that scales to the peak times and
we underutilized the capacity at other
times we save a lot of money some 10 min
each graph here's a graph of last year
we had about three projects that we were
rendering they were all sort of going on
at the same time including this project
we just showed you taking fight and you
can see three main things with this
graph one you can see that there's these
high peak types there's times when we
have enormous amount of renders and by
the way this is a graph of the amount of
hours each artists have submitted per
day to the farm the second thing you can
see as there's a times where we hardly
use anything maybe none at all and the
third thing is she is there's this
orange line that we sort of targeted
Mumbai and that's the sort of medium the
stuff that we use all the time and our
goal is to sort of have local compute
capacity for that median line anything
above that we want to push the cloud
because that's more cost-effective for
us but anything below that will render
locally at moonbot so our rendering
goals for implementation and moon but
was we wanted it to be easy to use we
wanted local and clouds they wanted a
hybrid approach and we only wanted to
use cloud when needed we didn't want to
treat cloud the way we do local knows
where we basically just spin up 50 nodes
that just sit there in the cloud we
wanted to only spin up nodes when we're
using them
and try to be smart about how that works
there's to render farm strategies that
we we sort of see either if we do
everything in the cloud you get sort of
the render everything as soon as
possible strategy and that's because if
you rent one node for a hundred hours
you're paying the same cost in the cloud
as renting a hundred nodes for one hour
so if it's cost the same why not render
it faster so that's great so that's
cloud only but with a hybrid farm you
sort of get a different approach you
have this local compute capacity you get
the best cost and savings when you fully
utilize the local computing capacity and
anything extra you push to the cloud but
with that you need a time component you
shouldn't need sort of a deadline for
each of your renders to be able to
calculate am I fully using my local farm
and once that's done you pushes the
cloud so to do that we present our
artists with this dialog sort of when
they submit stuff to the farm the first
option just ask them when do you need
this by and they can set whatever time
factor they want it defaults to the next
morning because a lot of times they
submit before they leave for the day
what this gives us our time factor to be
able to know when is a render being
completed by and if we have time with
rendered on the local farm and if not
we'll render it in the cloud so great so
why do we do choose Google Cloud to do
this three main things they have great
support so talking with them originally
they've helped us pick us a lot of stuff
and set up our pipeline to easily
support this they even suggested on the
second option of ear as our storage
vendor and I'll get a vet in one minute
and also they have permanent building
which is huge for us we only pay for
pretty much exactly what we use we're
not paying for our time slides that we
might not use the full capacity of so
implementing the cloud rendering into
our pipeline we sort of phase three main
challenges they like to share with you
some some details with those first is
storage how do we transfer our files to
the cloud to be able to render with them
so here's what we need to transfer we
need to transfer 3d scene files and
textures and then we need to download so
the rendered frames and maybe logs back
from them we're also in shreveport we
don't have the fastest internet
available we're sort of limited to this
100 megabit per second connection so we
have to be smart about what we're up
lending and when we're uploading there's
two ways that we saw that we could sort
of attack this problem the first way is
by writing sort of custom scripts
targeted to each application so what how
does the application low
data and we have to isolate all that
maybe parse the scene files or something
like that and then whenever you render
it out we have to target and find what
it rendered and transfer those back
locally but this has done very
individual application specific so we
also through Google's help we figured
out there's another solution called a
veer and this solution acts as like a
cache to your file system and because it
happens after the file system level it
can be sort of a one-size-fits-all
approach so let's look where that so
here's sort of a graph of how our
infrastructure is set up we have a
navire cash node that sort of sits in
the cloud and we have our core filer
that sits on site and they beer will
automatically upload data as its
requested to the cloud and the cal keeps
this cash that can be then distributed
to all the ringer notes the render nodes
connect into the beer and just ask for
stuff it doesn't have it it uploads it
from the core filer if it already hads
it it reaches serves it out of the cash
the way this works is it mounts the NFS
which is the same our way our local
storage handles which creates this knife
nice uniformity between our local cloud
and our google cloud makes it nice and
easy and also up auto uploads dependent
files since you're doing this just at a
file system level and also supports
partial file transfers so if you only
need like the top head of your file you
don't need to read the whole thing the v
are smart enough to only transfer that
part of the file so the other challenge
is how do we set up render nodes how do
we you know preferably have a uniformity
between how we have local mode set up
and the cloud notes we came up with this
workflow we take sort of a base OS we've
sent toss in our case on the cloud and
we run our configuration management tool
we use ansible and moon by to configure
our local nodes and then we can just run
that the same thing again in google
cloud on the base OS to get all the
software and configuration and
everything installed in a vm we then
bake that to an imaging google cloud
plug it into an instance template and an
instance groups to be able to spawn
pools of those notes there's two types
of instance types that we look at move
on there's the on-demand in pre-emptive
all nodes our goal at mumbai defers to
try to take advantage of the peripheral
nodes because they're less than half the
cost where they come with two side
effects they're available he's not
guaranteed and they also refresh after
every 24 hours the benefit though is the
render farms are capable of handling
fault tolerance to
like if a frame fails and a lot of
athlete ride so that's by nature as long
as the preemptive all instances aren't
too wildly unavailable we can take
advantage of this pre-emptive all
instances and take advantage of the cost
savings and we use instance groups to
manage the pools of instances this is
especially useful when you have
preemptive instances because their
availabilities not guaranteed it
sometimes they'll go away the instance
groups will automatically manage adding
the back if they ever become available
again so we don't have to write all the
code to handle that we're also able to
start and stop these pools of instances
and we sort of see a startup time of
about three minutes to get everything
ready so I can go into the instance
group say I need 50 nodes or a hundred
nodes and three minutes later they're on
my farm rendering and doing the work
instance performance was interesting too
we found that not all instances in
Google Cloud are the same be careful if
you're doing this because we found that
has well nodes we're about twenty
percent faster than the Ivy Bridge nodes
even though they might have a lower
clock speed for our specific rendering
applications and with that we sort of
saw an eighty percent performance
matched with cloud nodes compared to
local nodes so it is slower but the
benefit is we can have a whole lot more
of them so the last challenge we really
face is how to forecast renders so if we
want to do this hybrid approach how do
we really get that data to be able to
know when to submit to the cloud so what
we need to compute is some type of total
number of the pending render hours and
then from that they will get the delayed
render hours it's sort of a specific
point of time it's the way that we do
this is an artist submits their job to
the farm using the dialog like you saw
earlier we split it off into two main
groups we have sort of preview frames
and other frames so what that means is
you might have a shot that's about a
thousand frames long you would take the
first maybe middle and last and you
would render those of the highest
priority first maybe on your local farm
just whatever gets it done fastest then
you take the time that it took to render
those frames and use that to estimate
the time it's going to take to render
all of the other frames we do this for
each of the jobs that are submit to our
farm and we end up with a total count of
the pending render hours we then use
benchmarks of our local nodes to be able
to see how how much local capacity will
have in a certain amount of time and
then we can get a benchmark of how many
delayed hours there are in the cloud
use benchmarks of our clown nose to then
get an exact count of how many cloud
nodes will need to add for any time and
to complete our renters by their
deadlines it's great so that's most of
what we do in Mumbai to get everything
on side rendering and we end up with
these three main benefits we get
creative freedom we're more flexible we
can scale on demand removes constraints
on scheduling which is huge I can't tell
you how many times I've had to rebuy
jutt based on schedule shifting but the
cloud enables that to be much more
flexible it saves time we get faster
rendering simplified budgeted planning
and increased flexibility we pay as we
go we don't have to have this capital
expenditure upfront and enables us to
succeed as a company at moon by so thank
you and push it up a time thank you
thanks everyone for coming to our
session and hearing from our two great
presenters on how gcp has really enabled
them to dynamically scale their
businesses in a manner that's
cost-effective and it really most
importantly gives them a lot of creative
freedom so thanks again and we'll see
you all tonight at gcp after next after
dark
you